[Arabic recitation]
I would to share with you a few
verses of the Quran,
a few words from our messenger Muhammad
sallall.aii Wasam
with regards to the
immensity
of
in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's estimate
that
when a person learns
how to purify his intentions and purify
his actions and purify ultimately his
worship
from
anything that will compromise that
purity of
that this is the key to the acceptance
of all deeds.
This is the key to the gates of
paradise.
And this is the heaviest thing a person
can put in his or her scales on the day
of judgment
before Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
When sins are forgiven by Allah, they
are often forgiven because of the
intensity and purity
of a servant's of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
As we have mentioned before,
is not a
one unit that you either have it or you
don't.
There are things that compromise
a person's
in its entirety.
Meaning that a person's is invalid.
And that is a major act of shik
praying to other than Allah. And when I
speak about prayer, I'm not just
speaking about salah. Prayer, dua to
other than Allah
or calling upon other than Allah in
hardship with something that only Allah
can do
or slaughtering for other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And there are things that will
compromise a portion of a person's
meaning a person will still be Muslim
for all intents and purposes
but his has been diminished
deeply and fundamentally
such as
wearing trinkets for good luck.
good luck charms
or wearing or hanging trinkets
to ward off evil
or to deflect
and defend
from
evil eye etc.
or that a person does
or that a person implements s certain
superstitions
that will
allegedly
protect a person or protect a child.
Every single country on this planet has
some version of these kinds of shiki
yet.
These are spiritual landmines
that are littered throughout a person's
home, a Muslim's home, throughout a m
the throughout a Muslim's life that are
just waiting to compromise a person's
hate.
For instance, in certain countries,
they believe in putting a piece of metal
or iron under the pillow of a child to
protect the child from a Muslim
countries
or in others putting a bracelet on a
child to protect the child from a an
evil spirit.
While elsewhere they believe that if you
put a small mirror
at top a building or vehicle, it will
protect this vehicle or building from
evil spirits
and evil eye
or following horoscopes
etc. These are just a few examples of
many.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
the people of Mus Alisam
that when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
saved Musa
and delivered Musam
along with his brother Harun and Benny
is
how did he deliver them
when they were when they had the Red Sea
ahead of them and Pharaoh and his army
closing in behind them.
Those who were with Musam
feared and said
they said indeed we are done. Where are
we going to go? There's nowhere to run.
And the messenger of Allah
said,
"My Lord is with me and he will guide
us."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala told MS to
strike the sea with his staff,
his little staff.
Strike the sea.
And suddenly the sea split ahead of
them.
The scholars of Tier
from amongst the companions and tell us
that the sea was split into 12 paths.
One path for each tribe of Beni is
and they were delivered.
and Fyon with his arrogance and his
military
tried to pursue
only to be engulfed and obliterated by
the sea
after this incredible unprecedented
thing that they saw that they witnessed.
If you could imagine something this
with me, truly imagine
that you are standing in front of a sea
and Misam
strikes
the sea with his staff and suddenly this
water turns
into walls
and dries the bed beneath.
What a thing to see. What a sight to
behold.
You would think that after such an
experience,
a person could not find it in himself to
look to other than Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
How could you find it in yourself to
turn to other than Allah ever again
after seeing such a thing?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
chapter number seven of the Quran in the
story of Musam
after he was delivered by Allah with his
people
across the sea.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that when he
delivered Bani is on their journey to
the promised land. The promised land
being Philistine
that was written for them at that time
not now. It was written for them at that
time were they not so cowardly
as to not pursue what was
commanded of them.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that when he delivered them across
the sea
and they were headed towards the blessed
promised land.
They came across a people
that were worshiping
idols.
What kind of idolatry was it? Allah. The
Quran doesn't exactly describe
some of the companions
mentioned that
they were idols in the form of calves,
cows
that they were
adhering to and
exalting
and they were making there. meaning they
were camped around these idols out of
exaltation.
And when they came across these calves,
these idols in the forms of cows,
cattle,
this stuck in their heart
and it later came out as soon as MS left
them for a few days to go meet Allah.
The first thing they did
when MS was not watching them was make a
calf to worship.
However, before that, what occurred?
They said to MS,
they said,
"Make for us, designate for us
an idol, an image
they have.
Designate something for us. We want what
they have."
And this is one of the
one of the origins of innovation
and shik into
the the Muslims
traditions.
What is that? We can trace
most innovations in Islam back to a
minority living amongst a majority of
non-Muslims.
They see them doing something and they
want their own tradition that will
complement what they see the majority of
non-Muslims doing there.
We see that they have saints. We have
saints too.
They have a holiday. We have the same
holiday too. This is where innovation
comes from.
And so they said to Misam, "Desate for
us some idols they have idols." Now
we need to think for a moment. What was
their intention when they said this?
Were they saying to Misam
that they wanted idols to worship and
not worship Allah? They just saw the sea
split. They've been with Musam now for
years. He is teaching them about Allah
and
no this is not what
the intention was. The intention was
designate a shrine for us. Designate an
idol that will represent Allah for us to
worship.
Why? Because the idea is we want to be
able to go there and wipe it and wipe
our clothes on it and go there with our
problems and and this will represent
Allah. We know it's not a law but it
will represent Allah just they
have. It's something tangible, something
you can touch.
It's not
something that is obscure. No, it's
tangible. we can go there and we can
have our own shrines.
And so Misam,
he did not say, "Well, guys, we'll talk
about it later, but you know, this is
really not good, but I don't want to I
don't want to cause any division amongst
us, you know, just leave it alone for
now." No. Misam immediately said,
This is
and so what does this story have to do
with our subject today?
The prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
explained this verses
in an narration collected by
his
that is that some of the companions
had just accepted Islam. This was right
on the heels of the conquest of Mecca.
And
as they had accepted Islam, they
understood the broad strokes of Islam
and the generalities of Islam. But there
were still some
aspects,
some details that had yet to be learned.
And this narration is on the authority
of
He said, "We were with the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam on our way to
Hunain, the battle of Hunain, right
after the conquest of Mecca. Much of the
prophet's army was
consistent of the new Muslims that
had just entered Islam from the conquest
of Mecca. They were only Muslim for at
most a couple of weeks.
And so he said, "We were on our way with
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
and we came across a people that had a
giant tree
and it was referred to as anat
meaning the hanging tree." the hanging
tree. Why did they call it the hanging
tree?
They called it the hanging tree because
the warriors of this people
would go to this tree
and pray there
and perhaps fast. They would slaughter
there and they would hang their swords
and their spears and they would hang
their bows on this tree
and this was going to make their weapons
more effective in striking down their
enemies.
Notice here what the situation is. These
people, they are around this tree. They
are hanging their swords, their weapons
on this tree.
And the idea is that if they meditate
there at this tree, this tree will make
their swords strike down their enemies,
make their swords that much sharper,
make their bows that much stronger, make
their arrows that much more accurate.
This was the idea.
And so the companions here and these new
companions of them was
he said
Islam he said we were fresh new Muslims
we didn't know yet some of the
intricacies of
and so we were on our way to a battle.
So they said to the prophet sallallahu
alaii wasallam
They said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
designate for us a hanging tree just
they have a hanging tree. Designate
one for us."
What is their belief? These are Muslims,
companions. They've listened to the
Quran. They've prayed with the messenger
[Arabic recitation]
are not just you and I people that read
this through a book or grew up in a in
in a country with Muslims in it. They
were at the at the helm of Islam.
What was their belief? Was their belief
that this tree is they're going to
worship this tree? Of course not. That's
what they accepted Islam for. That's why
they saidahill.
The point here is that what they were
asking is designate a tree for us that
Allah can bless us through.
Right? A tree that when we hang our
swords on it, Allah blesses us through
this tree and blesses our armor and our
swords so we can more effectively strike
down our enemies.
This is what they asked.
This is what we call aar
in Islam
which is seeking good luck and charms.
And so what did our prophet say to them?
[Silence]
He said, "Allahbar,
these are the ways of the previous
nations. I swear by Allah, you have all
asked of me, what the people of Musa
asked of him after they were delivered
across the sea. designate for us idols
as they have idols.
This verse
was implemented by our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in this way.
We will
continue this inshallah next week. We
ask Allah subhanaha
that he teach us what we what will
benefit us and that he benefit us from
that which he teaches us.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
This is still on the time.
[Silence]
Allahbarb.
Allah
abarbah.
[Silence]
All
a shadow
Hallelujah.
[Silence]
Allah abar.
Just
got
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Muslim.
Foreign
[Silence]
was
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
in the opening verses of
he says subhanahala which translates to
indeed
verily this Quran
this recitation this book
does guide
to all that is best.
All that is best of what? Of every
aspect of a human being's existence.
Everything.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala didn't
identify exactly what it guides to the
best of
because what is intended by the verse is
that this Quran
it guides to the absolute best
and pinnacle of all that is best
everything.
Everything in a human being's life,
every good you can ever hope for,
every value you could ever hope to
acquire,
every esteem you could ever aspire to,
every evil that you fear.
This Quran
it guides to the best of every aspect
and facet of our lives.
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala furthermore
states in the same chapter
A bold claim,
a bold statement
that was challenged and challenged by
the enemies of Allah and his messenger
by the enemies of Islam and is still
challenged today.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
THAT IF THE HUMANKIND and the gin kind
all of them
not just the ONES ALIVE TODAY ALL OF
HUMANITY
THAT WAS and is to come and all of the
jankind were to collaborate
to produce a Quran similar to this Quran
they would not be able to do so even if
they were all somehow able to coordinate
with each other and get along in doing
so.
This is the book
that occupies our shelves.
This is the book that is just at our
fingertips.
All a person has to do is pick it up and
read it.
It has been served
by
scholars and students of knowledge
throughout the ages,
translated into every known language.
It has been pined over and explained and
expounded upon.
All a person has to do is pick it up and
read it.
Yet often times we fail to do so.
However, this is not the only pitfall
that faces a Muslim on his way on her
journey, his journey to Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
on the path of the Quran.
That path of the Quran
is a path that is broad and clear and
straight.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said
he said,
"I leave behind upon my departure.
I leave with you all two things that if
you hold to them truly you will never go
astray whether I am here or not. The
book of Allah and my sunnah.
He said, "Sallam
[Silence]
He says,
"I depart now and leave you all upon the
straight, clear, broad path.
It is so clear that its night is just as
bright as its day.
The only kind of person that will step
off of this path after having been
guided to it is someone who is upon sure
destruction. The hellbound
you have to try to miss the path of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So then how
does it HAPPEN IF GUIDANCE IS SO CLOSE?
IF IT'S RIGHT THERE, HOW DOES IT HAPPEN?
How is it that a person who reads the
book of Allah can still become
misguided?
Has this ever happened before? Yes,
of course it has happened
and it will continue to happen
because the human being as Allah sub
has said
because Allah subhanahua
described the human being and said the
human being is most proficient in
arguing. aring. That is the strong suit
of the human being.
They could argue their way into the
depths of hell
and make it seem a cakewalk.
The human being has the gift,
the gift of language, the gift of
deep meaning.
The human being has the gift to be able
a magician to present good as evil
and to present evil as good and to
change the truth into falsehood and
falsehood into truth.
This is the human being's gift and this
is the human being's potential curse.
Our
forefather,
our great imam,
our great companion of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said,
he said, "Those who are most modest
amongst my nation is a
he was referred to as
the man of two lights
because he married the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam's daughter
took care of her. She died as his wife
and then he married another of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's daughters
and she died as well as his wife and our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said if I
had a third daughter I would marry her
to him as well.
this manb a
forefather of the modern written Quran
to the point that the script and the mus
that is used by every Muslim today is
referred to as musi
the mani script.
He had preserved the Quran for us
with a decision
that had changed the course of Islamic
history and solidified the book of Allah
for
for the remainder of this dunya's time.
Who killed Arman Afan?
Manbin Afan was
imprisoned in his own home
above the age of 80.
man
was so devout with the Quran that he was
known to stand for one raq of w and
recite the entire Quran before fudman
at the end of his life as the of the of
the
khalifa of the messenger of Allah.
He sat in his home.
He had a nap on a day which he was
fasting
in which he saw the messenger of Allah.
Wasam and said to him, "Come and break
your fast with us tonight."
Awoke.
He opened the book of Allah in front of
him and he began to recite
just before the sun set before he was to
break his fast.
And a man raised his sword
and murdered
iban as his head hung over the book of
Allah. These were the circumstances.
WHO DID THIS?
WHAT EVIL DISBELIEVER would do such a
thing?
Who was the MAN WHO WOULD DO SUCH A
THING?
Was it the Romans?
WAS IT A CLANDESTINE ASSASSIN from the
Persians? No,
it was a Muslim.
It was a Muslim who had overthrown man
because he didn't agree with the way
Earth Man was running the empire.
THEY HAD STOPPED HIM FROM leaving Salah.
The likes of Abu Hurra,
THE LIKES OF THE COMPANIONS of the
prophet Sam. Wasam were barred IN THE
MASID OF THE PROPHET SAM.
Wasam from leading salah as they
imprisoned man because quote all of them
have
disbelieved had strayed from the path of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. These
young men they were the ones who knew
not the companions of Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam.
And it said THAT THE FIRST DROP OF HIS
BLOOD landed on the statement of Allah
in the
Allah will take care of them for you.
We fast forward.
The great companion
and warrior of Ali,
the great cousin of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, the man who
accepted Islam at the tender age of 12
or 13. The first of the youth to enter
into Islam.
He was KNOWN AS A FIERCE WARRIOR, a
great scholar,
THE HUSBAND OF THE best of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam's daughters.
He was married to Fatima,
one of the most virtuous women to ever
have walked this earth.
HE WAS THE FATHER of the two
most esteemed of the youth of paradise
at Hassan Hussein.
The only male grandchildren that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam had
they were referred to as
Ali
emerged from his home one morning
just before the break of dawn
to wake up
the caretakers of his masid in Iraq in
order that the adan be made and people
come to make salat.
And from the shadows emerged a man with
a sword.
And he struck Ali
in his head attempting to kill him.
He had fatally wounded him and mortally
wounded him.
Who was this man? Who could this have
been?
Was it the Romans?
WAS IT THE PERSIANS?
WHO WAS IT? It was Abdul Rahman ib
Muljim. Yes, his name was Abdul Rahman.
And this was not just any man Abdul
Rahman ib Muljim.
He wasn't just some ignoramus Muslim who
had just accepted Islam and was
brainwashed and used for political
agendas. No, Abdman Mulim
was appointed by Omar
himself and sent to Iraq to teach the
Quran.
That's that's who Abdahmanb
was.
He wasn't just any man.
Yet he EMERGED TO KILL ALI ABI. HOW
COULD this happen?
When they took hold of Abdul Rahman ib
Muljim
and they were to put him to death, they
said, these are the companions speaking,
we have never seen anything it. Not
a moment went by that he was not
praising Allah and remembering Allah and
reciting the Quran.
AND HE SAID, QUOTE, "TAKE MY LIMBS OFF
ONE AT A TIME. JUST DO NOT TOUCH MY
TONGUE because I cannot bear to exist in
this WORLD FOR A MOMENT WITHOUT the
remembrance of Allah upon my tongue."
That's the man who killed Ali.
And he did IT OUT OF SERVICE FOR ISLAM.
WHY? Because again he and his comrades
believed that Ali and Talib had
apostated from Islam. They were not
Muslim anymore. THEY DIDN'T JUDGE BY
ALLAH'S BOOK. WE JUDGE by Allah's book.
Joim mentioned in his book
that this is a disease that has no cure.
What is that disease?
Doing as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
that they
do the most evil of things
but they believe that they are the
purest of people.
How can you fix that kind of disease?
How can you teach someone who already
knows?
HOW CAN YOU FILL UP A GLASS
OF WATER IF IT'S UPSIDE DOWN and you
pour the water ONTO ITS BOTTOM? HOW HOW
IS THIS POSSIBLE?
All of these men read the Quran. They
read it. They memorized it. They
dedicated their lives to it. But this
was their fate. How
is Allah somehow unjust to these men?
Not at all.
These are men and women
who did not read the Quran.
Instead,
they sat down to lead the Quran.
They didn't walk behind the Quran. They
wanted the Quran to walk behind them.
THEY WEREN'T GUIDED by the Quran. THEY
SAT OUT TO GUIDE the Quran.
They read the Quran devoutly,
however they understood it, however they
wanted.
How does a person do this? What does
this look like? Am I in danger of doing
so? Absolutely.
The prophet sallall.aii WASALLAM SPOKE
about Abdulmanb
and his companions
and he defined THEM AS
THE DOGS OF HELL.
WHY? These are men that WORSHIPED ALLAH.
THEY FASTED.
THEY PRAYED. THEY RECITED,
but they did not read the Quran.
Instead, they attempted to lead lead the
Quran.
This occurs when a person already knows
something and then looks for it in the
Quran.
This occurs as the scholars tell us
that a person hold the belief and then
look for its evidence. THIS IS THE
FORMULA TO HELL and destruction
that A PERSON HOLDS A belief and then
look for it amongst the verses of the
book of Allah. This is the formula to
destruction.
WHEN A PERSON ALREADY KNOWS WHAT A
HUSBAND SHOULD be and then reads through
the pages of the Quran to find what
suits him. WHEN A WOMAN ALREADY KNOWS
WHAT SHE SHOULD BE AS A WIFE and then
reads through the pages of the book of
Allah to find what will bolster her
claim. A MAN WHO ALREADY KNOWS what
Allah is and is not and then looks
through the Quran to find what will
bolster his preconceived
notions and presuppositions.
This
is what led those treacherous, terrible,
lonely men to the fates that they
[Arabic recitation]
my brothers and sisters, our prophet Sam
has said,
[Silence]
He said
that the Quran
is an interceder on behalf of its people
and its intercession is accepted on the
day of judgment.
And the Quran is an opponent that is
unbeatable.
If a man or woman comes before Allah
with the Quran as his opponent,
they will have no chance.
He says, "Sallam,
whoever places the Quran in front of
him, it will guide him to paradise.
And whoever places the Quran behind him,
it will shove him into hell.
We ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that he
grant us the enlightenment, the wisdom
to recognize the truth when we hear it.
That he grant us the courage to adhere
to that truth in spite of the
consequences. That he grant us the honor
of DYING FOR AND UPON THAT TRUTH. and
that he grant US THE NOBILITY of being
resurrected and raised before Allah with
the people of the truth.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
for
now.
I All
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
All
becommen.
[Silence]
genetic.
forham.
[Silence]
He was heavy.
Alhamdulillah.
Allahbar. Allahbar.
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Everyone
take a moment to observe your two
neighbors on either side of you. Ensure
that you're standing on the line. Ensure
that your feet are in line with the feet
of your two neighbors. That your
shoulders are in line with the shoulders
of your two neighbors. Take a moment to
check your phones. Make sure that they
are silent so as not to interrupt our
dialogue before Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Straightening the row is part of the
perfection of salah. If our rows are not
straight, our hearts will become
[Arabic recitation]
I could
Allah
belt.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
amen.
for
[Silence]
All
me.
Allahbar.
Allahel.
[Silence]
All
I could
[Silence]
Shadow
shadow.
[Silence]
Assalamu.
Stuff for Allah.
[Silence]
Salam.
Okay.